hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on 400 again and as you
can tell by the vid
oh sorry was i interrupting something
anyway uh as you can tell by today's
video we're gonna be talking about the
rise of the warmonger event pass
obviously there's an event coming with
the new hero and
ubisoft allowed me early access to talk
about some of the stuff
involved with that and one of those the
event pass it's gonna be 35 tiers as you
see here
and if you get the year four season two
battle pass
you get a 10 bonus so we're gonna talk
about all that today
in today's video and i have no idea what
to expect in this past it's completely
unfiltered for this video so
not gonna be too much editing but yeah
starting off with tier one we got a new
outline not too bad
this is yeah actually it's not too bad i
feel like that's
a really nice outline on tier 2 we have
250 salvage
a nice emblem for the samurai that's not
too bad i'm not i've always never really
been a big fan of emblems per se but
it's not a big deal
and xp boost a tier 4 same emblem but
for the knights of tier 5
same for the uh before the wool in at 6
100
100 steel then we get the viking version
250 salvage i do a battle outfit which
is the
belligerent archon not too bad it's got
a nice color
you know a little nice yellow color
scheme to it doesn't really fit too much
with many of my characters but
i do actually appreciate the emblems it
comes with though those are nice looking
emblems
that's gonna be for the woolen the
vikings is at 11
with the samurai at 13 and the knights
at 15.
we then have 100 steel and one xp boost
at 12 and 14. for 16 we got 250 salvage
and then 17 18 19 and 20 is
the new con which is the new ornament
for the groups
not bad probably not the greatest idea
to use this on conquer right out the way
because
that just doesn't look right at all
i would say i feel like that would fit
with most
uh with like some characters i would
definitely say if we go to the preview
here i feel like it'll work
really well with warmonger and black
pryor yeah i feel like these are the
type of emblems that work
really well with the kind of like the
new characters the harbingers anybody
with shoulder ornaments i feel like
that fits well with any other character
just looks really awkward to me
that's gonna be 17 through 20. going to
21 we have an xp boost
22 through 25 is a new idle effect which
is
an axe that just comes from the sky is
if that's what i'm getting right
now that's all right so that was raiders
weapon
that's her weapon
that's her weapon again
that's not her weapon so it seems like
it's
a different weapon every time i'm not
necessarily sure if this is a
if this is a looping type of effect
where that's how long
it is it's one of those infinitely
playing ones or every time you do the
idle effect it happens to just drop a
new weapon either way looks really
really cool
it's your 26 we get 100 steel 27 through
30
is going to be an emote effect with
that's a lot of different weapons
all right that was a lot better
nice so instead of it being one weapon
per effect it's now
five different ones all right that's
gonna be for every single you know
character
27 through 30 and then 31 through 34
is the execution effect
oh they actually go into the character
this time
nice and then at 35 we ended with a
scavenger crate
not too bad of course usually these
passes per se
are very short obviously there's only
going to be like a couple we're not
going to be getting a large amount of
days
as compared to the year 4 season 2
battle pass but still
this ain't too bad i think this is
pretty solid uh i wouldn't say this is
obviously one of the best things we're
getting in the world but of course it's
an event pass that's the
the whole reason like i said there's not
gonna be some crazy [ __ ] there's not
gonna be weapons involved that's just
for the regular event not with the pass
but it's not too bad i feel like these
effects could definitely fit with a few
characters in the game
some of them are really nice looking and
i'm actually a really big fan of this
outline
but yeah that's gonna be the rise of the
warmonger event battle pass
once again like i said there's gonna be
35 tiers full of crazy rewards and you
can obviously progress through
a lot of these by doing daily rewards
matches and arcade quests
and as it says here purchase the year
four season two battle pass in order to
start receiving a 10
bonus so you can earn it even faster
yeah let me know what you guys think
about the event pass in the
in the comments down below that like to
be if you do enjoy the subscriber for
you
and take care see you in another video
[Music]
bye
[Music]
hmm